In 12th century Italy, a tower was under construction
in the town of Pisa.
The design was for a beautiful, freestanding
bell tower in the finest romanesque style.
But as construction of the third level began,
something went wrong: the whole tower began
to tilt.
And by the time it was finished, everything
was noticeably leaning to one side.
Thankfully, the mistake was seen as charming
by visitors.
And eventually, it turned into a global icon
and tourist attraction.
But for the Civic Tower in Pavia, which was
built around the same time, structural problems
led to a fatal collapse in 1989.
The next year, a team of Italian engineers
was formed to prevent the same fate in Pisa
6while maintaining the tower’s iconic tilt.
For both buildings, the problem wasn’t just
above the surface.
It had to do with the support of the foundation
underneath.
And since modern structures can be many times
larger, the stakes are much higher – you definitely
don’t want a leaning skyscraper on your hands!
So to keep things standing tall above ground,
you need to look at what’s going on below it.
[Theme Music]
Civil engineering is about creating the infrastructure
we need for the places we want to live.
Roads, bridges, tunnels and ports all require
planning to build, and maintenance to keep
working safely and efficiently.
And infrastructure supports vital networks
like water and power supplies.
In fact, the US National Academy of Engineering has
made repairing and improving infrastructure one of its
grand challenges for the 21st century.
And as we learned in Pavia, a structure that’s
going to last needs to be on a solid foundation.
And that’s where geotechnical engineering comes in.
At least for now, the infrastructure we build
is connected to the ground.
Even the sturdiest, most well designed building
won’t last if the land supporting it isn’t up to the task.
So geotechnical engineers spend a lot of
their time investigating the rock and soil that
structures are gonna be built on.
As well as building on top of the ground, engineers
often dig into it, like for a harbor or a dam, or tunnel
through it, as in the case of underground train tracks.
In each of these scenarios, you have to
consider how the ground’s characteristics
might affect the structure’s stability –
a consideration the designers of the
Tower of Pisa overlooked!
We’ve seen before how forces like crosswind
and the weight of the materials can affect a building.
Many of the same lessons apply here.
The foundation of a structure is the part
that actually connects to the ground and
transmits forces to it.
So that might be columns or walls that extend
into the ground, for example.
And they’re as much a part of the structure
as the bits we can see.
To stop a building from falling over, sinking,
or snapping, it needs to be supported through
its foundation by a reaction force.
In other words, the soil needs to resist the
force transmitted through the foundation.
Soil might seem pretty straightforward.
After all, it’s just dirt, right?
But, in reality, soil is one of the most complex
environments engineers work with and it comes
with a lot of variety.
Just like other materials and fluids, soils and even
rocks have mechanical properties that make them
suitable or unsuitable for building on top of.
If enough force is applied, the ground itself
can shift and change shape in intense ways.
The capability of the surrounding soil to
withstand those forces is its bearing capacity:
how much force can be transmitted over a given area
without causing the ground to drastically change shape.
Just like a solid material, soil can actually
undergo failure in the mechanical sense!
At that point, it no longer fully supports
the structure, which is what happened to the
Leaning Tower of Pisa.
The foundations of the tower weren’t deep enough
to support it after it reached a certain height.
That meant the stress applied by the tower’s
mass was bigger than the soil’s bearing capacity,
which ultimately shifted the ground
and tilted its foundation.
Bearing capacity is tricky to calculate, but essentially it
depends on both the depth and design of the foundation
and the qualities of the soil that you’re building into.
Since you usually can’t control the soil,
you need to understand it and build a foundation
that accounts for any potential problems.
The main property you’ll be interested in
is shear strength.
As the foundation applies the load to the ground,
the soil redistributes the force, creating tension
throughout the region around it.
Just as we saw for materials, everything has a
certain internal resistance to shear stress – the
kinds of forces that act in opposite directions.
There are other kinds of stresses to consider,
but shear stress is the most important because
it’s the one most likely to lead to failure.
Layers of soil that push past each other can
quickly stop supporting a structure’s foundation.
The shear strength is the measure of the shear
stress the soil can tolerate before it reaches failure.
The higher the strength, the more stress the
soil can resist before it finally gives way.
It’s one of the biggest factors that
determines the bearing capacity –
you generally want the soil to be as strong as
possible to ensure as much stability as you can.
The trade off is that stronger soil can sometimes
be a little tricker to excavate in the first place.
And some structures, such as bridges, have
to be built in particular locations.
So you often have to work with whatever soil
happens to be there!
The key to understanding the strength of a
particular piece of ground is that soil isn’t
one homogenous thing.
Instead, it’s best to consider soil as a
collection of tiny grains of rock and leftover
organic matter from living things.
The exact materials differ between soils,
but in geotechnical engineering, the focus
is on the size and shape of those grains.
That’s where the soil gets its strength
or weakness from.
It helps to think of the concept of viscosity,
which we encountered in fluid mechanics.
When the soil undergoes shear stress, the
friction between the layers of soil helps resist
the stress and give it solidity.
One of the causes of that friction is that
the grains interlock with one another and
resist any change to their arrangement.
If things do move, there’s the added friction
of the particles rubbing together.
Both of these contribute to the shear strength.
Separate from friction is what’s called
cohesion, or the tendency for smaller particles
to stick together, like in modeling clay.
In fact, it’s often tiny particles of clay or silt
that are responsible for cohesion in soil.
So the more clay it contains, the stronger
it will be.
The size and shape of the grains, and the cohesion
between them, are just some of the properties
geotechnical engineers use to estimate shear strength.
The full picture would take into account all
the complexities of the soil,
including its mineral composition, moisture levels,
and the size of the grains themselves.
Not to mention the fact that strength isn’t
constant throughout the ground.
It can be radically different for buildings on
opposite sides of the street, or even at different
depths under the same structure.
So you’ll want to be sure to do a detailed
analysis.
That will guide you in designing a foundation
that provides the bearing capacity needed for
what you’re trying to build.
In 1990, a year after the Pavia tower collapsed,
the Italian government set up a team of engineers
to tackle the problem of Pisa’s bearing capacity.
In the weak soil underneath the Pisa Tower,
three-meter deep foundations weren’t enough
and the tilt was slowly getting worse.
After trying different approaches, engineers finally
weighed down the side of the tower opposite the tilt with
lead and removed some of the soil from that side.
In doing so, they managed to sink the
foundation a little further into the ground,
increasing the contact area between it and
the soil, and improving the bearing capacity.
The shifted weight of the tower even
compressed the soil at its foundation,
actually improving the soil’s strength!
Now it’s thought that the tower should be
safe for at least 200 years, all while retaining
its iconic lean.
While that’s great news for Pisa, other parts of
Italy are prone to a different ground-based problem.
Because of fault lines in the Earth’s tectonic plates,
regions in Italy are susceptible to earthquakes, like other
areas across the world.
In 2016, a powerful quake caused devastating
damage to the buildings in central Italy.
Protecting against the effects of earthquakes is
exactly the task seismic engineering is there to tackle.
That’s why these people are often known
as earthquake engineers.
While they share many techniques with geotechnical
engineers, seismic engineers have to worry about what
happens when the ground itself starts moving.
A violent movement can subject the foundation
of a structure to a load larger than its bearing
capacity can handle.
Worse still, the soil might undergo what’s
called liquefaction,
in which loose, sandy soils lose virtually all
their strength and behave like a liquid, which
spells disaster for anything built on top!
In addition to modeling the soil like
geotechnical engineers,
seismic engineers have to break out the full
toolkit of statics and dynamics to understand
the whole structure.
In fact, because the effects of an earthquake
are tricky to simulate, seismic engineers often use
what’s called finite element analysis.
They use computers to model every piece of
a structure and predict the exact stresses
and strains each piece might feel.
Just to be sure, scale replicas of entire buildings are
often built and tested on oscillating platforms to
demonstrate the real, physical effects of an earthquake!
While destroying a model bridge might sound
fun, the goal is to test designs and see where
faults arise, so they can be made safer.
In combination, geotechnical and seismic engineers make sure that structures remain standing tall from top to bottom when they encounter stress at their foundations.
In environments dense with infrastructure, like cities,
it’s a critical job for the safety of everyone nearby.
And this means we can continue to enjoy the
Tower of Pisa for centuries to come.
In this episode, we looked at geotechnical
and seismic engineering.
We learned how structures connect to the ground
and transmit loads through their foundations,
and how those foundations need to provide
a high bearing capacity.
We also saw how properties of the soil, like
shear strength, affect bearing capacity.
Finally, we considered what happens when the ground
experiences stress from seismic activity and how
seismic engineers work to counteract those effects.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll engineer
ways to get from one place to another!
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios,
which also produces Hot Mess, a show
about how climate change impacts all of us,
and what we can do about it.
Explore how we can create a better future
for our planet and ourselves by checking out
Hot Mess at the link in the description.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.